NOW TOEWS GETS I THE ZONE.
CENTEN
THE PERIOD.
>> Eddie: OVER IN THE MID.
ICE.
THIS PUCK  UP AND OVER THE
NET.
>> Todd: IT'S BLOC UP AND
OVER, BUT TOEWS WINS T FOOT
CE.
THE RECOION OF JONATHAN
ALL. SHOW NO HESITA AT
ONCE THAT PUCK WENT UP AND
OVER NET.
HE KNEW ANDERSON WL.
KARLSSON FOT
SPEZZA TRIED TO BANK IT OFF
PUCK IT BOUNCED IT TO THHE
RICTED AREA AS HE SCURRIED
CAUG
WILL GO HERE, BUT JOHNNY ODUYA
W.
.
DRIVES THE NET.
UP, GETS IN BEHIND AGAIN,
KARLSSON, PAT, CHEATIN
THAT PUCK IS GOING OUT HIGH.
HE ALLOWEWS TO GET THE
HES KEITH.
AND PHILLIPS ABLE TO GET OUT.
P BACK IN.
ERED IT HOSSA FOR SEABROOK,
Eddie: PAT, WATCH WHAT END
HAPPENING.
THE OT SENATORS ARE IN A
SPOT, BUT WATCH WHAT
PPENS WITH THIS PLAYER RIGHT
HERE.
AND WHEN THAT HAPP THE HAWKS
TURN THE PUCK OVER.
AND THEN JONATHAN TOEWS WI
WORK HIMSELF IN IT TO THIS AREA
IN THE FRONT OF NE
WATCH WHAT HAPPENS.
TH SORS' PLAYER LOSES HIS
STICK, IT'S A  ON THREE AND
THE FRONT OF THE NET.OES I
WHAT DOES ?
STOPS IN FRONT OF THE NET.
AND WHEN YOU STOP, YOU AOING
TO GET A LOT OF  GOALS
JONA TOEWS WHO HAS THE WRAP